peter les fêtes de bayonne ont baissé
leur rideau ce week end les sentes aux
touristes des souvenirs chamarré
inoubliable aux agapes autour d'un
traditionnel pioro la soupe de poissons
que l'on déguste en groupe dans des peña
taurine
autre spécificité de la région paul de
genève et ils jeunes car une image 11
heures du matin bayonne se réveille
doucement
quelques tables son nom p porte
d'espagne le bouquet est trop fort le
chef d'orchestre ce héros c'est louise
cuisinier en titre de la peña or compan
associations traditionnelles fondées sur
la culture et la gastronomie de la
région
c'est du poulet y ait une recette une
recette espagnol et en fait ça me
poulets qu'on fait revenir dans de
l'huile qui est parfumée à l'ail et ont
fait une pré cuisson et après on fait
une dernière et puissant avec une petite
force et qui est un petit fumée le
volaille l'heure du repas est aussi un
peu à l'espagnol
ces heurts les 400 invités passat 1
en entrée du taureau une soupe de
poisson titre c'est le déjeuner annuel
de la peña au complet pour les bayonnais
un des événements les plus courus des
fêtes l'association est basée sur la
confiance sur l'amitié
on les 50 membres qui rentre sur votre
présentation des amis et après un repas
commence à lui si c'est chaque membre
qui invite ses amis
qui leur permet de passer au fait de
festoyer 400 personnes
c'est surtout un rendez-vous de vieux
amis éparpillés le restant de l'année
aux quatre coins de la planète venir
l'été sans période
je me répète c'est qu'on mange et enfin
son repas sans manger du commun le
boulanger qui pue
à
mua
à yverdon
porto d'espagne l'après-midi s'écoulera
ainsi entre amoureux du pays basque